what's the other thing on the horizon
for humans uh in terms of the sun
burning out all those kinds of
interesting cosmological
threats to our
civilization well i think
only
cosmological time together because it
won't be humans because uh
something else even if evolution has
gone no faster than darwinian
and i would argue it will be thousands
in the future uh then um we're thinking
about
six billion years before the sun dies so
any entities watching the death of the
sun if they're still around maybe it's
different from much as we are from slime
mold or something you know
and uh far more different still if they
become electronic so on that time scale
we just can't predict anything but i
think going back to um
uh to the human time scale um then um
we've talked about
whether there'll be people on mars by
the end of a century
and uh even in these long perspectives
then
indeed this century is very special
because it may see the transition
between
purely flesh and blood entities to those
we saw sort of cyborgs and that'll be an
important transition in um
in in biology and complexity
in this century but of course the other
importance and this has been the theme
of a couple of my older books is that um
this is the first century when one
species
namely our species
has the future of the planet in his
hands
and that's because of
two types of
concerns
one is that there are more of us
we're more demanding of energy and
resources and therefore we are for the
first time uh
changing the whole planet
through um
climate change loss of biodiversity and
all those issues this has never happened
in the past because having enough humans
have been much empowered so this is a um
an effect that's obviously it's high in
everyone's agenda now and rightly so
because um
we've got to ensure that we leave a
heritage that isn't eroded or damaged to
future generations um and so that's one
class of threats but there's another
thing that worries me
perhaps more than many people seem to
worry and that's the uh
threat of misuse of technology
um and so this is particularly because
um
technologies
empower even small groups
of uh malevolent people or
indeed even careless people
to create
some effect which could cascade globally
and um
to take an example um a
a dangerous pathogen or pandemic
i mean my worst nightmare
is that there could be
some
small group that
can engineer a
virus to make it more variant or more
transmissible than the natural virus
this is so called gain of function
experiments which were done on the flu
virus 10 years ago and can be done for
others
and of course we now know from covet 19
that
our world is so interconnected
that a disaster in one part of the world
can't be confined to that past and will
spread globally so it's possible for a
few dissidents with expertise in biotech
could create a global catastrophe of
that kind and also i think um
we need to worry about very large scale
disruption by cyber attacks in fact um i
quote in
one of my books a 2012 report from the
american pentagon
about the um possibility of a state
level cyber attack on the electricity
grid in the eastern united states
which is it could happen and it says at
the end of this chapter that this would
merit a nuclear response
this is a pretty scary possibility that
was 10 years ago and i think now
what would have needed a state actor
then could be done perhaps by a small
group in power by ai and so there's
obviously been
an arms race between the uh um the cyber
criminals and the cyber security people
not clear which side is winning but the
main point is that as we become
more dependent on more
integrated
systems
then uh we could get more vulnerable and
uh um
and and so we have the knowledge
then the misuse of that knowledge
becomes um uh more and more of a threat
and and i'd say bio and cyber are the
the two biggest concerns um and uh if we
depend too much on ai and complex
systems then um just breakdowns it may
be that they they break down and um um
even if it's innocent breakdown then it
may be pretty hard to mend it and just
think how much worse the pandemic would
have been
if we'd lost the internet in the middle
of it and it was we depended more than
ever for communication everything else
on
on on the internet and zooms and all
that um and if that had broken down that
would have made things far worse and
those are the kinds of
threats that we i think need to be more
energized and politicians need to be
more energized um to uh minimize and um
one of the things i've been doing in the
last year um through being a member of
our part of our parliament is sort of um
i have to instigate a committee to think
more on better preparedness for um
extreme technological risks and things
like that so they're a big concern in my
my mind that uh we've got to make sure
that we um can benefit from these um uh
advances um but safely because um uh
the stakes are getting higher you know
the benefits are getting great as we
know huge benefits from computers but
but also huge downsides as well
and one of the things this war
in ukraine has shown
one of the most terrifying things
outside of the humanitarian crisis
is that at least for me i realized
that the human capacity to initiate
nuclear war
is
greater than i thought
i thought the lessons of the past have
been learned
it seems that we hang on the brink of
nuclear war with this conflict like
every single day
with just one
mistake
or bad actor
or
the actual leaders of the particular
nations launching a nuclear strike and
all hell broke breaks
so then
adding to that picture cyber attacks and
so on they can
lead to to confusion and chaos and then
out of that confusion
um
calculations are made such that uh a
nuclear launch is
a nuclear weapon is launched and it's
and then you're talking about
i mean i don't the directs probably 60
70 percent
of humans on earth are dead instantly
and then the rest
i mean it's uh basically 99 percent of
the human population is wiped out in the
period of well
that's real devastation for civilization
of course and of course we're quite
right that this could happen very
quickly um because of uh um
information coming in and there's a
there's hardly enough time for human
um collected and
careful thought and there have been uh
recorded cases of false alarms the
several where um
where there have been suspected um
attacks from the other side and uh um
fortunately they've been realized to be
false alarm soon enough but but this
could happen and there's a new class of
threats actually which
in our center in cambridge people are
thinking about which is that um
the commander control system
of
the nuclear
weapons and the submarine fleet and all
that um is now more automated and uh
could be subject to cyber attacks and
that's an a new threat which didn't
exist um 30 years ago and so um i think
indeed it's it's we're in a sort of
scary world i think
um and uh
it's because things happen faster
and human beings aren't in such direct
and immediate control because so much is
delegated to machines um and also
because the world is so much more
interconnected
uh then uh
some um
local event can cascade globally in a
way it never could in the past and much
faster
yeah it's a double-edged sword because
the interco interconnectedness
brings um
brings a higher quality of life across a
lot of metrics yeah it can do but of
course
there again i mean if you think of
supply chains where we get stuff from
around the world then um one lesson
we've learned is that there's a
trade-off between resilience and
efficiency and it's resilient
to have
an inventory in stock and to depend on
local supplies where is it more
efficient
to have
a long supply chain
but the
risk there is that
a break in one link in one chain
can screw up car production this has
already happened in the pandemic so so
there's a trade-off and there are
examples i mean for instance the other
thing we learned was that uh
it may be efficient to have 95 of your
hospital intensive care beds occupied
all the time which have been in the uk
situation whereas to do what the germans
do and always keep 20 of them free for
an emergency is really
a sense of a precaution and so i think
we've probably learned a lot of lessons
from kobit 19 and they would include um
rebalancing the trade-off between uh
resilience
and efficiency
boy the the fact that kovan 19 a
pandemic that could have been a lot a
lot worse
brought the world to its knees anyway
it could be far worse in terms of its uh
fatality rate or fatality right yeah
so the fact that that i mean it revealed
so many flaws in our human institutions
yeah yeah
and then i think you know i'm rather
pessimistic because um
i do worry about the uh
the
bad actor or the small group who can
produce catastrophe
and
if you imagine someone
with access to the kind of equipment
that's available in university labs or
industrial labs and they could create
some dangerous pathogen um then even one
such person is too many
and how can we stop that because uh
it's true that you can
have regulations i mean academies are
having meetings etc about
how to regulate these new biological
experiments etc make them safe but even
if you have all these regulations
then enforcing regulations
is yeah pretty hopeless we can't enforce
the tax laws globally we can't enforce
the drug laws globally and so similarly
we can't readily enforce the um uh
laws against uh people doing these
dangerous experiments even if all the
governments say they should be
prohibited and so my my line on this is
that
uh
all nations are going to face a big
trade-off between three things we value
um
freedom
security and privacy
and i think uh
different nations will
make that choice differently um the
chinese
would give up privacy
and have more certainly more security if
not more liberty
um but i
think um
in
in our countries um i think we're going
to have to give up more privacy
in the same way that's a really
interesting trade-off um but
there's also something about human
nature here where i personally believe
that all humans are capable of good and
evil
and there's some aspect to which we can
fight
this by encouraging
people
incentivizing people towards the better
angels of their nature
so uh in order for a small group of
people to create to engineer deadly
pathogens
you have to have people
that for whatever
trajectory took them in life wanting to
do that kind of thing and if we can
aggressively
work on a world that sort of sees the
beauty
in everybody and encourages
the flourishing of everybody in terms of
mental health in terms of meaning in
terms of all those kinds of things
that's one way
to fight the development of um
uh of weapons that can lead to
atrocities yes and i completely agree
with that and to reduce the reason why
people feel embittered yes um
but of course we've got a long way to go
to do that because uh if you look at the
present world um nearly everyone in
africa
has reason to feel embittered because um
uh their
economic development is lagging behind
most of the rest of the world and the
prospects of getting out of uh the
poverty trap is
is rather bleak especially if the
population grows because for instance um
they can't develop like the eastern
tigers by cheap manufacturing because
robots are taking that over
so that they will naturally feel
embittered um
by the inequality and of course um what
we need to have is some sort of
mega version of the marshall plan that
helped europe in the post-world war two
era um to enable africa to develop that
would be
not just an altruistic thing for europe
to do but in our interest because
otherwise
those in africa will feel massively
disaffected
and indeed
it's a manifestation of the excessive
inequalities the fact that the 2000
richest people in the world have enough
money to double the income of the bottom
billion
and uh and that's uh um you know an
indictment of the ethics of the world
and this is where
i've my friend stephen pinker and i have
had some contact we wrote joint articles
on
bio threats and all that um but um um he
writes these books being very optimistic
about quoting figures about how uh um
life expectancy has gone up infamous has
gone down literacy has gone up and all
those things and he's quite right about
that um and so he says the world's
getting getting better and
do you disagree with your friend steve
pinker
well i mean i i i agree with those facts
okay but but i think he misses out he
misses out part of the picture and
because um there's a new class of
threats
which uh um hang over us now which
didn't hangovers in the past and i would
also question whether we have
collectively
improved our ethics at all because um
let's think back to the middle ages it's
true that as pinker says the average
person was uh
in a more miserable state than they are
today on average um for all the reasons
he quantifies that's that's fine um but
in the middle ages there wasn't very
much
that could have been done to improve
people's lot in life because of lack of
knowledge and lack of science etc um so
the gap between the way the world was
which is pretty miserable and the way
the world could have been
which wasn't all that much better it was
fairly narrow
whereas now
the gap between the way the world is and
the way the world could be
is far far wider
and therefore i think we are ethically
um
more uh
at fault
in allowing this gap to get wider than
it was in medieval times and so i i
would very much question and dispute the
idea that we are ethically um in advance
of our predecessors that's collectively
a lot of interesting hypotheses in there
and i don't
they're it's a it's a fascinating
question of how much
is the size of that gap between the way
the world is in the way the world could
be is a reflection of our ethics or
maybe sometimes it's just a reflection
of a very large number of people
uh like maybe it's a a technical
challenge too it's not just what about
political systems political systems like
how many
and we're trying to figure this thing
out like there's 20th century tried this
thing that sounded really good on paper
of collective the communism type of
things
and it's like
turned out at least the way that was
done there
at least the atrocities and the
suffering and the murder of tens of
millions of people okay so that didn't
work let's try democracy
and that seems to have a lot of flaws
but it seems to be the best thing we've
got so far so we're trying to figure
this out as our technologies become more
and more powerful have the capacity to
do a lot of good to the world but also
unfortunately have the capacity to
destroy the entirety of the human
civilization and i think it's social
media generally
which
makes it
harder to get a a sort of moderate
consensus because in the old days when
people got their
news
filtered through responsible journalists
in this country the bbc and they made
newspapers etc and they would muffle the
crazy extremes whereas now of course um
they're they're on the internet and if
you click on them you get something
still more extreme and so i think we are
seeing a sort of
dangerous polarization which i think is
going to make all countries harder to
govern and that's something which i'm
pessimistic about so to push back it is
true that brilliant people like you
highlighting the limitations of social
media is making you realize
the
the stakes and the failings of social
media companies but the same time
they're revealing the division it's not
like they're creating it they're
revealing it in part
and so that puts a lot of
uh
that puts the responsibility into the
hands of social media and the
opportunity in the hands of social media
to alleviate some of that division so it
could in the long arc of human history
result so bringing some of those
divisions and the anger and the hatred
to the surface so that we can talk about
it and as opposed to uh
disproportionately promoting it actually
just surfacing it so we can get over
well you're assuming that the uh the fat
cats are more public spiritual than the
politicians and i'm not sure about that
i think there's a lot of money to be
made in being
publicly spirited i think there's a lot
of money to be made in increasing the
amount of love in the world despite the
sort of public perception
that
all
the social media companies heads are
interested in doing is making money
i think
that may be true but i just personally
believe people being
happy is a hell of a good business model
and so making
as many people happy
helping them flourish in a long-term way
that's a lot of way to make people
that's a good way to make well i think
on the other hand guilt and shame are
good motives to make you behave better
in future okay so that's my experience
in my experience
from maybe in the political perspective
of certainness in case yeah but it does
make sense now that we can destroy
ourselves when nuclear weapons with
engineered pandemics and so on that the
aliens would show up
that
if i was
the
um you know had a
leadership position
maybe as a scientist or otherwise in an
alien civilization
and i would come upon earth
i would try to watch from a distance
do not interfere
and i would start interfering
when these life forms
start becoming quite they have the
capacity to be destructive
and so
i mean it is an interesting question
when people talk about ufo sightings on
all those kinds of things
that at least these are benign aliens
you're thinking
benign yes i mean they
benign almost curious
almost
um
partially as with all curiosity
partially selfish to try to observe is
there something interesting about this
particular evolutionary system
um because i'm sure even to aliens earth
is a curiosity yeah
but it's very special stage
in especially
perhaps in this century is very special
yes among the 45 million centuries the
earth experienced already so it is a
very special time where they should be
especially interested but um i think
going back to the um the politics and
the other problem is uh getting
people who have short-term concerns to
care about the long-term by the long
term i now mean just looking 30 or 30
years or so ahead you know i know people
who've been scientific advisors to
governments and things and
they may make these points but of course
they don't have much traction because as
we know very well any politician has an
urgent agenda a very worrying things to
deal with and so um they aren't going to
prioritize
these issues which are um longer longer
term and less immediate and don't just
concern their constituents if they
concern distant parts of the world um
and so i
i think i think um what what we have to
do is to um
enlist
charismatic individuals
to convert the public because if the if
the politicians know the public care
about something
climate change as an example um then uh
they will
make decisions which um uh uh take
cognizance of that um and i think for
that to happen then we do need some um
public individuals who are respected um
by everyone um and who have a high
profile and in the climate context
well i i would say that i've mentioned
four very desperate people who've had
such a big effect in the last few years
one is pope francis the other's david
attenborough the others bill gates and
the others greater thornburg and those
four people have certainly had a big
shift in public opinion um and uh uh
and even change the rhetoric of business
although how deep that is i don't know
and so yeah
but
but politicians
can't let these issues drop down off the
agenda um if if there's a public clamor
and it needs people like that to keep
the public clamor going to push back a
little bit so those four are very
interesting and i have deep respect for
them they have
except david and bro uh david edinburgh
is really i mean everybody loves him i
mean i can't say anything but the you
know with bill gates and greta there
there is that that also has created a
lot of division oh sure
and this is a big problem so it's not
just charismatic
i i put that responsibility actually in
the scientific community and pope does
too yeah yep uh and the politicians so
we need
the
charismatic leaders and they're rare
yeah when you look at human history
those are the ones that make a
difference those are the ones that
um
not deride
they they inspire
the populace
to think long term
the jfk we do
we'll go to the moon in this decade not
because it's easy but because it is hard
there's no discussion about
like um
short-term political gains or any of
that kind of stuff uh in in the vision
of going to the moon
or going to mars or taking on gigantic
uh
projects or taking on world hunger or
taking on climate change or
uh the education system all those things
that require long-term significant
investment
that requires but it's hard to find
those people and yeah and incidentally i
think another problem is
which is a downside of social media is
that um
of younger people i know
um the number who would contemplate a
political career
has gone down because of the the
pressures
on them and their family from social
media um it's a hell of a job now um and
so i think we are all losers because the
quality of people who choose that uh
path
is um
is really
dropping and as we see by the quality of
those who are in these compositions that
said i think uh the silver lining there
is the quality of the competition
actually is inspiring
because it's
it's it shows to you that there's a dire
need of leaders which i think would be
inspiring to young people to step into
the yeah yeah
i mean great leaders are not afraid of a
little bit of a little bit of uh fire on
social media so if you have you have a
20 year old kid now a 25 year old kid
is seeing how the world responds respond
to the pandemic seeing the geopolitical
division over the war in ukraine seeing
the brewing war between the west and
china
we need great leaders and there's a
hunger for them and the time will come
when when when they step up i i
i
i believe that but also to add to your
list of four
he doesn't get enough credit i've been
defending him in this conversation elon
musk in terms of the fight and climate
change
uh but he also has led to a lot of
division but
we we need more
david annaberg yeah no no i mean i i'm a
fan
definitely i mean i've heard him
described as a 21st century brunel for
his innovation and that's true but uh um
whether he's a an ethical inspiration i
don't know
you